the ACLU is an important organization of
the ACLU in fact became the ACLU right
at the time of the Red Scare Wilson's
Red Scare and in response to that severe
repression and since then it has a
pretty admirable record of its
conservative rec it's a conservative
organization very conservative the term
conservative is another one of those
that's been distorted out of any
relation to its meaning but in the real
sense of the term conservative the ACLU
is a conservative organization which is
trying to preserve basically
conservative values 18th century values
and it does a pretty good job on it
it's had bad periods it went along with
McCarthyism for example and it doesn't
take the really hard cases those are
taken by more militant civil rights
organizations but it has done very good
things it's very striking fact that
about the political system do you recall
what happened with the ACLU in the last
elections the Republicans attacked
Dukakis as a card-carrying member of the
ACLU that's a very interesting phrase
that means an organ card-carrying of
course means real really communist you
know that's what that's supposed to
imply so here's an organization that's
committed to defense of the Constitution
and according to the Republicans
that's communist well you know I think
that characterizes modern conservatism
it's really a profoundly reactionary
movement which is deeply opposed to the
values that on which the country was
established and that's why they would
call a an organization calling for the
defense of the Constitution a subversive
organization now what was the Democrats
defense against this charge that they
were that Dukakis supported the
Constitution his defense was to deny
that he supported I mean he didn't say
yeah of course I'm a member of the ACLU
and proud of it what he said is what he
gave it they published a list of cases
of the ACL u--'s that he disagreed with
that was the republic Radek response
well that tells you something about
Aelita pinyon I know I don't think the
ACLU is an illusion I think it's an
important organization I'm proud to be a
card-carrying member and to speak at
their meetings and stuff I
I think there are more courageous
organizations to take harder cases